after a year hiatus the sponsors of this
segment great american foodie fest is
back and i couldn't wait to stop by and
check it out earlier today to give you
guys a preview take a look
it's a very exciting news foodie fest is
back after a one year hiatus and the man
behind it all this is noel the founder
of the creator of it all how many food
trucks we got out there this year we
have about 30 food trucks and about 20
food vendors this year it's big we
missed you guys last year how does it
feel to be back this year well after
three castle events and and two years of
doing nothing it's it's amazing to be
back it hasn't even started because the
doors open at five and i already feel
like a food energy and a festival energy
going on let's walk around here so the
doors open at five how much is it to get
in
so it's seven dollars pre-sale they go
right now before five o'clock okay after
that at the gates ten dollars to get in
so jump online right now get your
tickets in advance it's not only just
great food that you guys have but
there's also great carnival rides what
are some of the rides we have here this
year we have some amazing rides there we
have the kamikaze we have the zipper we
have the ferris wheel we have we
actually have a new new uh carnival this
year the car that we used last year went
out of business so this is an awesome uh
carnival that we came across though the
gallery at sunset as i'm pulling up
that's the first thing i see is the
gigantic beers will and i'm walking up
here i start hearing the carnival rides
going on it's a festival uh event
tonight perfect for the entire family
something you're bringing back this year
and a lot of people are excited about no
more cashless systems no more casters
i'm glad you mentioned that because a
lot of people complained about that
no more magic money is what we use this
is called magic money no more and so uh
also too um are there eating contests
happening this weekend we always have
eating contests every year absolutely
what are some of the contents that you
guys do uh hot beef jerky contest egg
roll contest is a mobile contest let's
let's uh yeah sorry you're a busy man
you got calls coming what are some of
the uh some of the vendors they're gonna
be out here this weekend what style of
food are we gonna have
well you name it we bring out some of
the best food trucks not only here
locally but some of the best food trucks
that have been featured on the food
network cooking channel travel channel
from all over the country brought to one
local destination that's the foodie fest
it's it's huge i missed you guys last
year
let's talk about parking um are you guys
charging for parking no no charging
there's something for everyone it really
truly is a family event absolutely
absolutely yeah bring the family and the
kids and stuff you can win some prizes
you can eat lots of food
oh is there music here this year so we
just have a live dj this year due to
covid restrictions we just wanted to
keep it simple
so no live bands but you have music you
have a dj yeah absolutely so there's
gonna be entertainment out here tonight
and starts tonight five o'clock what are
the hours going this weekend so friday
five to eleven saturday 11 a.m to 11 p.m
and then sunday 11 a.m to 10 p.m did you
mention so many uh food trucks you have
out here in the carnival rides i think
you need to come out here more than one
day absolutely that's why you buy one
ticket it's good for all three days are
you serious all three days unlimited
re-entry i want to give the website so
the website is
greatamericanfoodyfest.com right you got
it jump on there now buy your tickets
advanced because they're only seven
dollars buy now noel thank you so much
buddy i appreciate it thank you brother
come out to foodie fest you guys
thank you again to great american foodie
fest for sponsoring this segment the
festival starts tonight five o'clock and
lasts through the weekend it's out there
in henderson call them for more
information at 702-410-8565
as mentioned pre-sale tickets only seven
dollars ten dollars at the door great
american foodie fest.com that is a
worthy seven or ten dollars